[Music]
um
foreign
is
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
is
hello i'm ann hornaday the washington
post's
chief film critic welcome to our oscar
spotlight series we are putting the
spotlight
on the five films nominated for academy
awards
for best documentary feature and today
we're speaking about collective a
documentary out of romania
joining me now are the film's director
alexander nanao
and kathleen tolenton the investigative
journalist
whose work is the basis of this
incredibly powerful film
gentlemen welcome hello
thank you for having us good afternoon
and thank you for having us
i dressed like that as a bingo announcer
because for us as a journalist
the the presence in front of the leaders
of the washington post is like a
night of the oscar awards really i say
this is not because
i don't go to the lay ceremony because
there are no seats
and it's fair because the restricted
pandemic ceremony
was more as one but really because
this incongruous cross skype between the
newsroom of uh
romanian sports daily and the curiosity
and the
right to know of a global audience uh
make us feel like uh
like the night of the the oscar awards
that means the world it means the world
coming from you and anybody who has seen
your work and the way you do it in this
film understands that the honor is
truly ours so thank you thank you both
for being here
um and alexander congratulations
you have earned romania's first oscar
nomination
and not just two one nomination for best
documentary feature but for best
international feature as well so
congratulations two times over
thank you very much yeah it is it is a
great honor and
um means also a lot not only for sure
for
for the remaining cinema because you
know romaine cinema
has shown its its quality since many
many years
around the world uh but also because it
is this story that
really um is so important for the for
the romaine society
indeed and i'd like for you to tell us
just a little bit we did learn the the
the
um the sort of outline of the story in
that trailer but
so let's refresh some memories here a
lot of us do remember
that 2015 fire in the nightclub called
collective it was a bucharest
nightclub in romania 25 27 lives were
lost but then
the story deepened and so could you just
explain to us briefly
what happened and what you cover in the
film
yeah so the starting point was
basically what happened after the fire
you know uh many people took the
streets in many cities around romania
uh mostly a young generation
demonstrating against
the political class of their parents uh
world basically a political
class of populism incompetence and
corruption
and on top of that came the manipulation
that took care
in the health care system that they can
treat these burn patients which was a
big lie
which was done systematically by
politicians health care officials and
doctors
uh and many more people died in
hospitals because they could not be
treated properly basically so from that
on
i wanted to try to understand
power who you know who these people are
in power that use their power
uh to manipulate and knowingly
uh you know killing people although they
promised everybody and the parents that
they will rescue them and have
all the all the medical
uh you know preparation to do that
um so when we saw that catalin's team
is investigating the health care system
and and the power we saw
maybe that's the best way for an
observational documentary not only to
see
the victims and their stories but to try
to understand
powers through the eyes of investigative
journalism
and that is so fascinating to me it
looks from the from the way the film is
structured it looks like you
got in really early in terms of covering
catalin's investigation is that true
you did you so his investigation and the
team's investigation was already
underway and you just zoomed right in
with your cameras or how did that
tell us a little bit about how you uh
the logistics of all of that
yeah we were basically we became aware
of of the team at the gazetta through
two investigations first the first one
was on the firemen
the fire department they were lying that
they didn't know whether
that the club existed when it actually
was a popular
venue and it was a venue that they
authorized to function
and the second one was when they found
out that the only really
equipped burn unit in the country was
not giving surgery to these patients as
they said but it was closed down
and so when we when we approached them
and stepped in
they were basically just about to to
find out
and also publish um about the hospital
infections that
existed and and cataline
you are again you are the you and your
team are the central characters to this
amazing film
which we'll get into this later it
unfolds like a thriller like a
journalism
a classic journalism thriller and you
get to the
heart of this medical scandal
involving a disinfectant
and this is all the more astonishing
because
you're a sports newspaper i understand
is that right
yeah that's right but we have we have
working in investigation for more than
20 years and we have
some results of course for for us
results mean
information for the public but sometimes
for the public results
means punishment for the corruptions
and the people trust us we gain the
trust
of the people in in time time means not
months or even years but decades
this is the true bound between the the
journalists and the
the the public all over the world and
they came to us
with some tips some
news just after the fire in two or three
days
and we do our job because you know
i saw your colleagues write under my
name
investigative journalist i don't know if
it's something like this
we are all news journalists first
yes uh and every big investigation
is in the first stage in the in
in its inception only a small news
and if if you are struggling seeking for
the facts
not for the truth because i think it's a
very interesting distinction because
between the facts and the truths okay if
you are
seeking for the facts maybe maybe you
are going after
a big case of investigation
but it starts with the fact that's
that's that's a wonderful lesson
that's a wonderful journalistic lesson
to be that we should all be reminded of
um you know this
this film addresses sorry if i if i if i
have my end
but you you your your your audience from
us
know very well this kind of uh
needs because i i saw the the first uh
speech of president biden and i think it
it was the first speech in the u.s
and maybe the the democratic uh
country's history uh in which the
the phrase effects was applause
was collected that the applause from
from
from the from the people from the the
audience
or affects themselves as president biden
says
this is our society right now we need
facts we need facts
and we need transparency and it's
interesting my colleague margaret
sullivan
has a column just today about a study
that shows that
for a lot of american citizens they
don't value facts
and transparency the way journalists
would value those values and so there's
there's an interesting disconnect which
makes it all the more interesting to me
that the romanian citizens obviously
like you said you had built up trust
and accountability with them so that
they felt like they could come to you
and and get response but did you sense
among them
were they cynical about their
institutions or did this come as a
complete shock because
the institutional rot uh
goes sort of throughout romanian
societies so how
tell me a little bit about the citizens
and their level of cynicism about
institutions
oh this is very very interesting
discussion because
you know five years ago martin baron the
former editor of boston globe
wrote an article in washington post just
in the day of
oscar awards five years ago and uh
uh uh he wrote something like this i'm
i'm in spotlight but it's not about
me and it's not it's and it is about
journalism the power of journalists uh
he says
if i may add i think i mean collective
but it's neither about me nor the power
of journalists
it's about the right the need and the
struggle of the public to
to have access to facts in order
to ensure the maintenance of uh
democracy and then the the
the maintenance of institution of course
because
you know we have a lot of debates in in
our team
with alex just today we have a debate um
and he told me you always quote
too much but this is my profession i
have to quote
and i i read in a in an indian newspaper
first post is the name the comparation
and you made also this kind of
compilation in your
review about collective last year
about uh friedrich griezmann weissmann
score
sorry for the pronunciation and uh uh
alexander
now and i come back to your to to your
question about
the bound between people and institution
and democracy yes uh
and the magic of cinema which is capable
to
put these kind of layers together
and uh the the the the indian
uh journalists uh uh wrote something
like this
wise men are working on in one
institution only
about uh universities sometimes for
berkeley was the name of the
the movie now city hall was the the the
most
recent uh wise man movie
but alexander now says the the indian
journalist
work on on the more
horizontal uh layer of the democracy and
i think
something like this okay first it's
about pillars it's about
legislature it's about media it's about
city halls and the second way which is
i think it's it's uh it's proper uh
and very uh reliable uh shows in
in collective uh with the huge
work and the uh talent of alexander
it's about the the bricks of democracy
and for me this is the definition of the
of the collective movie because i think
for more than
one year what what is collective it's
about despair or it's about hope
it's about corruption or it's about
incompetence it's about
the abuse of the power or it's about
integrity
it's about the involves of the citizen
or the despair of the democracy
i don't i think it's about the breaks of
the democracy the day-by-day
uh concrete segment of
democracy i couldn't agree more that's
very very well said
and ultimately it's it's the bricks are
the people
and that actually sets up a clip i'd
like to
play a clip that really gets to the
emotional core of this
um and and it's and i think that's
another gift of this film
is that along with this
incredible investigation in the third
sort of thriller aspects
alexander you never lose sight of the
human cost and the human stakes
so um let's play this clip that shows
the heartache behind
these losses and then we'll come back
let's watch
is
foreign
m
alexander what has the film
meant to those parents do they feel um
i mean i it seems almost trivial just to
ask if a movie has brought them
extra layers of accountability or an
extra
extra feeling of having been seen and
heard
but has the movie helped them
process the trauma and feel like they
have been seen and heard
i think that you know i think that the
toughest screening i ever had
uh in my career until now was the
screening when
um when we finished the film we invited
all families and um victims of the fire
to
to see the film uh in a in the same room
in the cinema
uh and it was tough because i didn't
know
you know it was such a test for us to
see if these people
accept what we have done as their story
uh
and it was a relief afterwards because
they came and and you know said like
this is the most realistic thing
we have seen about what we went through
i was for sure
a bit afraid if they might say you know
it's not enough about us
it's too much about journalism and and
uh politics but basically
i think that they they felt that
this description of society and
of these different forces that basically
influence
your life and what happened to them i
think that is reflected in a way
how they felt all this time after it
happened how many
different forces basically you know
people manipulated them
uh part of the press failed them um
you know all these different layers of
also
injustice until today there's no
final sentence to not to find
the people that are responsible for the
fire or
for the mistreatment of these kids in
the hospitals
or there is no final sentence to for any
compensation
so you have these young people many of
them students just started jobs made
maybe
uh mutilated by the fire there's no
compensation they live
you know they can't really live a life
because
some of them maybe can't do their job
anymore
uh so i and then after you know
in this whole award season and after the
nominations
uh narcissist the father that we have
just seen
uh has written on facebook that
like kind of a letter to his son that
you know we couldn't help you because we
didn't know better when they lied to us
but at least now other people can
see the story and one of our greatest
wishes
was always to share your story
and help other people not go through the
same thing
hopefully they can they can realize in
time
when they are manipulated or you know
what rights they have
absolutely and that goes for everyone
including americans i mean this was so
relevant to our own to our own
i mean it's a universal story and a
cautionary tale and i think
another sort of irony or a contradiction
is that on the one hand i'm so impressed
that romania submitted this film
you know and that this was romania's
choice to submit to the academy it's now
been nominated
so you have this kind of strange
contradictory situation where
this film that's kind of an indictment
of institutional
laxness um that is still going on as you
point out is also being celebrated i
mean
are you getting support from the
romanian people and romanian
is a government uh
one has to say that the
the fact that this film was chosen is
the result
of the oscar rules the ampers rules are
very clear it has to be an independent
commission
that decides upon the film not the
government not the state institution so
the state institution names in romania
five independent film journalists
film critics and they cast a secret
ballot
right and that's how the film got
nominated and we have faced
quite some difficulties
with the state institutions because our
film was chosen
they tried to cut any funding for for
the campaign
um i you know i had my right with them
after they couldn't uh reverse the
decision they looked for
uh in in the ambush rules you know they
they told me like we looked at
everything and next year we will let the
open public
vote for the film
and after they couldn't harm it
for real they tried to embrace it and
they tried to award me a medal of honor
for my merits to culture and i said
no thank you i mean that's not going to
work
because it is a government that since
the pandemic has started
has done nothing for the cultures there
is no
not a single financial mechanism to
support uh the institutions that were
closed or the
the the artists so
i i could not just play this fake game
with them
sorry one second but this is a proof
that institution matters in the
democracy
even if in a political bias
environment like romania or
like uk or like u.s if you have if you
have institutions
and you protect them at citizen and
community
as community they are working
better and better
it depends always on the you know on the
individual also the institutions you
know it depends so much
how well as we see also in the film
you know it depends sometimes on one
person
that does not abide
to corruption does not abide to what
the system has created as as you know
misusing its power and i think that's so
important what
that's also what i think was enforced in
in myself
uh doing this film that it comes down to
everyone's life attitude
you know if your life attitude if your
attitude is right this will
you know spread to other people and
that's the way you can turn things
around or
uh you know repair in a way
society exactly
just opposite it for me it's not about
one person and about persons i think
it's about
institution and your movie collective
it's about institution
because we saw a lot of institutions
like press conference
this is institutions in romania
we have some some function
between our citizen and the
the the states
how about right of course you are right
because and this is the bitter paradox
because romania as ant says
romania put on the oscar list
such a critical movie about
their reality
i want to get a clip in of kathleen
being interviewed
about his investigation and then come
back on the other side we can keep
talking about these issues
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
so as i said earlier i i actually think
it's both and i think
this shows institutions are important
but it also shows individuals like you
cataline are important
institutions don't work unless the
people who populate them have
integrity and courage which you
displayed throughout this film
and which other figures did too but have
you
experienced repercussions for your work
are you still able to do the work you
need to do and the way you need to do it
yes and i think our first fear is
not about states about to big pharma
companies about to
mobs now our first fear is about
to abandon the facts to me to mistakes
yes
to make mistakes because the people
feels
when the journalists abandon facts for
the confirmation or for the applause
sometimes
and uh when we when we abandon
news for them for the entertainment i
think
here is the magic of the the the movie
because
not only of the collective movie because
i saw the
the the the the dissident i saw the uh
for
summer the cave in last years
and i think when the
fact became fiction and at entertainment
as today
all over the world i think the people
go to the fiction world of cinema though
to seeking the facts of course
documentary movie
is not journalism and you wrote and a
lot of
about this kind of bound and this kind
of
difference between uh journalism and the
documentary fiction documentary movie
but the people
seem so so impressed and so
so emotional uh struggle
in them and they are they're seeking for
the truth and for the facts
in in this kind of uh of movie i don't
know how
i don't know how because him is magic
for me as journalists
alexander and the other directors
works in this kind of in this kind of
style i don't know how i don't know how
really it's a
it's a miracle for me and
put the people in in front of the fact
we're grateful for the work i want to
very quickly alexander i
must not let you go and we are almost
out of time but i do want to ask about
min
the health minister vlad who's one of
the protagonists in this film
could you give us a very quick update on
on where he is right now
yeah so uh you know things changed a bit
in romania in the last
two years i think people voted
differently we have some reformatory
parties and he became part of
one of these parties two years ago they
won enough votes to
become part of a coalition government
and he
became minister of health last
christmas so three months ago
and since then for sure
scandals around kobit have happened that
were not so much his fault
uh because they came with the
mismanagement of of the system
before but today he was basically
kicked out by the prime minister with no
warning um the prime minister decided
that
vladimir should not be anymore the
minister of health
because he is uh i think they think he's
too weak uh but
that had many things that happened
before he
uh that catalin was also involved in
this uh he published his
the theme of blood published data about
vaccination and the journalists could
discover that
there were more secret vaccine stations
for the
elite so to say than for the vulnerable
people
and for the open public and they were
forced by that to
to open vaccine stations to the public
the those secret ones and
a lot more things that come with you
know intentions to transport
um how the money is spent in the system
and so
many think that these are the real uh
reasons why he was kicked out because he
started to transport
the system and uh transportation
in a system that in crisis enriches many
people
is maybe the last thing power really
wants
yes but i have to keep the critical
distance as journalists between me and
the
ministry of health and from my point of
view he is not
a victim anymore because he made a lot
of mistakes also
of course he have a lot of enemies
in the from the corruption
layer of the romanian society but i
think
this is also the the the proof from the
main message
uh from collective movie because
the highest position in democracy is not
a cuba superhero
like a health ministry it's a citizen
they the citizens are in the highest
position in democracy
that is the perfect way to end this
fascinating program which i wish could
go on forever but we're
out of time alexander catalin thank you
so much for joining us today and
congratulations again
on your nomination thank you for having
us
thank you very much
you